permettre à chaque aidant à travers un
groupe de parole autour d'un café de ce
conflit aux autres et d'échanger des
expériences attend résumé l'objectif du
café des aidants
c'est sur le site de l'espace régler au
bas de la rivière que ghislaine solent
chenilles guy et tous les autres aidants
ont décidé de venir raconter les
difficultés de cette vie un peu à part
sa maman
voilà
ça y est
et voilà
sèmassi café des aidants j'ai su par
rapport
le repos et puis la démarche était pour
échanger un peu avec les autres
personnes dans le même cas que moi
encore alors cette première expérience
la première demi heure là ça s'est très
bien passé c'est émouvant coin parce
qu'on entend pas mal le court sous terre
les histoires des autres et voilà à quoi
donc donc je suis pas tout seul il ya
d'autres personnes aussi dans le même
même situation que moi et les échanges
là ça permet de se tenir là justement
les difficultés voile et je rencontre
d'autres personnes et d'autres personnes
rencontrent aussi donc ça me donne plus
de comment vous dire plus de courage de
force et je dis que je suis pas tout
seul maladie d'alzheimer handicap d'un
enfant accident cardio-vasculaire la
conjointe de leur vie un jour basculer
dans la maladie il faut alors apprendre
à vivre avec et faire les sacrifices
nécessaires pour continuer à assurer le
quotidien de ces personnes malades déjà
de partager parce que comme au départ
encore moins s'il était dur et bien de
faire comprendre aux gens que
vivens onana des moments de lassitude
des moments d'incompréhension des
moments de doute aussi face aux demandes
est-ce que variés on va pouvoir assurer
est ce que on va pas pouvoir lâcher même
si c'est un moment en soi un moment
donné on connaît plus où mettre de la
tête parce que nous n'en avons aussi
bien aux enfants que les enfants à un
moment donné dit mais on la phase de
poules par an et qu'on les partage un
petit peu dans tous les sens parce j'ai
retenu outre le moment pas pas assez
bien en cela il faut courir avec tout ce
qui est administratif de ski et médicale
pour tous qu'il faut quand
développé sur le plan national le café
des aidants milite pour la
reconnaissance du rôle et de la place
des aidants dans la société c'est le gps
ap maison de l'aide à la personne qui
met en place ses cafés et qui s'entoure
de professionnels pour apporter les
réponses nécessaires à la détresse de
ces aidants notamment au niveau des
dispositifs existants le café existe
dans le département lors à l'espace
règle et l'autre à la case grand terre à
l'autre de ces pour rencontrer d'autres
personnes parce que moi je veux aussi au
groupe de parole au niveau de
l'association alzheimer donc un jeudi
par mois
et comme il y avait ça aussi le mercredi
donc je viens ici aussi quoi on parle on
programmait oui oui oui on voit déjà les
l'évolution de la maladie
et c'est important c'est pour eux
d'échanger des expériences de diab
allemagne pas tout seul
voilà on oscille maman difficulté à
l'ansa voilà informés les aidants des
dispositifs mais surtout les encadrer
c'est le rôle des agents du gts ap à
l'image de miki des prêts de la
psychologue qui interviennent lors de
ces rencontres des changes de
convivialité de partage où comme vous
l'avez vu certaines émotions peuvent
être
partagez donc ça donne un sentiment
salle et permet aux personnes de sortir
du sentiment de solitude d'épuisement et
ça leur permet de faire participer des
autres ça crée des liens
vous avez aussi il ya des personnes qui
vont échanger leurs numéros de téléphone
se constituer en réseau à voir des
personnes vers qui se tourner en cas de
difficultés une séance qui dure en
moyenne deux heures et qui permet aussi
aux étangs de créer du lien car souvent
ces derniers s'échangent leurs numéros
de téléphone pour se soutenir jusqu'au
prochain café